il semblerait que nous soyons au plafond
sociologique c'est à dire que le désir
d'enfant soit parfaitement satisfaits
dans notre pays et que même si on
multipliait les aides on n'obtiendrait
pas un gain énorme et donc la question
est-ce qu'il faut des bébés ou des
immigrés elle est pas opérante puisque
on ne peut pas décider selon ma thèse
selon moi si on est au plafond
sociologique d'avoir comme ça du jour au
lendemain par une législation par
exemple même par des aides économiques
plus de bébés nationaux premièrement
deuxièmement sur les 10 milliards un
chiffre en 1950 l'onu avait prévu qu'en
l'an 2000 nous serions 6 milliards c'est
exactement ce qui s'est produit c'est à
dire qu'il est très difficile de faire
des anticipations être prêt pour tout ce
qui concerne le monde sauf pour une
chose c'est la démographie et la l'onu a
bien prévu qu'on serait 9 points 5
milliards en 2050 compte tenu de du
fonctionnement de ces anticipations
j'aurais plutôt confiance d'autant plus
qu' on a évoqué la queue vite 19 qui va
changer totalement à la marge les choses
et puis alors le dernier argument que
j'ai entendu qui est absolument
formidable c'est celui de gérard
françois dumont qui finalement va tout à
fait dans mon sens et qui me dit nous ne
serons pas finalement 10 milliards
puisque la crise environnementale est
telle que les gens vont crever comme des
mouches donc cqfd
il faut faire des enfants c'est pas
grave pour l'environnement puisque à la
fin ils crèveront tous à cause de
l'environnement
j'adore le raisonnement je préfère pas
les mettre au monde voyez plutôt que de
les voir mourir de famine de guerre
mondiale je ne sais quoi parce que les
risques vont être extrêmement important
dans un monde à + 2 ou 3 degrés et puis
là il ya une dernière chose qui a été
dit qu'ils étaient très intéressantes
c'est ça dépend de l'enfant qu'on fait
peut-être que votre enfant français ça
va être un génie qui va résoudre le
problème du réchauffement climatique
alors oui c'est tout à fait possible que
ce soit un génie mais en attendant votre
enfant quand il va naître il va pas
s'habiller en pagne et manger des
racines c'est à dire que votre enfant
français comme tous les français il va
émettre en moyenne 10 tonnes de co2 et
même si c'est un génie in pourra mettre
en oeuvre sa géniale invention qui va
nous sortir de l'ornière climatique
qu'au bout de 30 ou 40 ans d'études
assez poussée et dans l'intervalle et
bien le monde va continuer de se
réchauffer
[Musique]